[Music]
what we know
senior chief kelly is the third member
to be attacked
three perps are dead
also killed was his wife
they better hope he doesn't survive why
is that
he is more dangerous and effective than
any man we have in the field
he took everything from me
these were foreign attacks on u.s soil
we have to respond
i'm gonna make it right
there's something inside of me that i
can't turn off
a part of me that won't stop for
anything
no remorse
as it occurred to you that perhaps john
kelly
has done something we can't
some situations aren't thinking outside
the box
give me your name you are supposed to be
dead give me a name
[Music]
[Music]
it's a world of opportunity
and i was meant for more in this life
[Music]
i want to make art and i want to make
trouble
whether you have the killer instinct is
the big question
i hope i don't know
[Music]
hear me roll all right we should put on
some music or something
lighten the mood
we can go anywhere do anything
we just got to stick together we
underdogs have to look out for each
other right
underdogs
[Music]
see the whole world together
[Music]
it'll be amazing
[Music]
but there's just one thing
wait did you see that no one can find
out
[Music]
where did you boys say you were from
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so gave us a fake name again
again
not sharp thank you i just don't
understand why he keeps doing this you
don't understand i feel like it's pretty
obvious to spoil things
i don't spoil things you're thinking
maybe one thing that i've actually
spoiled
the last movie title
[Music]
i've never seen a being as strong
maybe one
is back
[Music]
i spent a lot of time trying to divide
us
i made a promise to him on his grave
[Music]
i need to bring us together
there are enemies coming from far away
they serve an old power
this world is divided
no protected here no lanterns
no kryptonian it will fall
in his name
[Music]
i have turned worlds to dust
all of existence shall be
mine
[Music]
i have a second chance i am not gonna
waste it
[Music]
he said the age of heroes would never
come again
fighting the devil in his army
you know i don't care how many demons
has fallen how many hells
he's never fought us united
it's time to stand
fight
the time
is now
[Music]
great what's uh fair price for that
village
200 i just need that village clear today
all right
if they refuse cut their tongues out
red notices have been issued for the
notorious black swans a family-owned
private military company linked to
alleged atrocities in the republic of
georgia
the sas is about to move on us to
confirm this is a hard arrest you'll
serve the red notice
race is special everyone is replaceable
race isn't dead boss
[Music]
i love being with you tom i don't
understand you
let's talk about this in paris haven't
said yes yet don't be late
major breaking news the euro stream
train
has been hijacked
my father taught me all about these this
one carries gas to homes across the uk
if you don't pay us i will destroy this
tunnel and
everyone in it if she exposes what we've
done this is a very big problem for me
get down there and kill her
there's a player in the battle space
he's armed and skilled
he's looking for a way under the
carriages
what are you doing
this isn't about money it's revenge
we're more alike than you know
let me help you embrace who you really
are
on your knees with your hands behind
your head that's far enough i tried to
help him i swear
we are at war and the war is secret this
unit is the last line of defense against
a truly terrifying force
condition to kill but also to deceive
we shall continue the operation but do
not engage
they took me when i was four years old
they kept me prisoner they
did things to me i can protect you
no you want me to trust you enhanced
i've been turning up dead all across the
country
one of your own taking you down from the
inside
there's no safety and no control we will
all die
nothing will save me
his body is human and it still bleeds
but he regenerates instantly
david can't open the doorway until he's
harvested every single subject he'll
come for you
and i had nothing to do with that know
it none of them did they're not people
they're weapons
he's coming for them and anyone's
standing in the way
[Music]
hey jake can i get a large bottle of
that baiju
you know what they get too large
how can you drink like that i used to
complain that every day felt the same
and now every day is the same hey
i have died 144 times and every day ends
like this
but it doesn't matter not when you've
lost everything you've loved
venter man who's had me killed 150 times
the power to rewrite history is mine
heads up i know everything that's gonna
happen
one thing that never changes what's up
pretty boy
a bunch of [ __ ] are killing me for
reasons that remain a mystery
i am guanyin and guanine had done this
right right
[Music]
it's for you roy can you hear me you
can't explain it right now but i'm gonna
need your help gemma
the only woman i've ever loved and who
can stop this is still alive
i have to get killed over and over again
until i save her you need to learn how
to fight with a sword
i would only have a day i think we can
get a lot done in a day
[Music]
someone's been the busiest little beaver
exactly
bring them all
i can do this all day
she's here
listen i have a story for you something
the examiner will love
a healing possibly divine
a girl performing miracles after a
visitation from the virgin mary
in chicago new york dc every demographic
on this planet
is eating this up give me the exclusive
all right i think i got this all set up
what do you say we do a couple
real easy questions how many are gonna
watch mary wants to reach as many people
as possible
maybe millions
[Music]
there are people out there that don't
believe in your miracles
how would you respond to those folks
[Music]
seeing is believing and why do you think
mary chose you
i opened myself up and welcomed her in
witnesses of the virgin mary draw
millions of faithful
each year the vatican's been tasked to
investigate
this visitation from the blessed virgin
i have read several libraries worth on
the supernatural
investigate half of those miracles
prove him all false
[Music]
she's here you think there could be
other forces at play here
when god builds a church the devil
builds a chapel
next door don't doubt her
doubt weakens faith
[Music]
hail mary full of grace pray for us
sinners
now and at the hour of our death
this is not the work of the virgin mary
it's the work of the unholy
faith in evil and poverty love
believe in her
offer your souls
to mary
holy mary mother of god the lord is with
you
once upon a time
in a far away land called washington
heights
say it so it doesn't disappear
washington
lights up from washington heights up at
the break of day i wake up and i got
this little punk i gotta chase away
pop the great at the crack of dawn sing
while i wipe down the awning
hey y'all good morning ice cold feet i
got teddy strawberry and just for today
i got my mate
it's a story of a block that was
disappearing the genius is
back yo he should just ask her out right
now hey
something on your shirt
smooth operator
we all had a suenito and when it came to
dreams
we had to keep scraping by maybe this
neighborhood is changing forever
maybe tonight is our last night together
however i just want to see the whole
world through our eyes
they're talking about kicking out all
the dreamers it's time to make some
noise
we had to assert our dignity in small
ways
little details that tell the world we
are not invisible
this is the moment when you do better
than me because you can see a future
that i can
but you made all of this
this is me
they used to say you work hard
you live by the rules the money will
come
the things will come you ready
i've been saving up all my pennies in my
piggy bank for this day today's all we
got so we cannot stop this
[Music]
the best
for what is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
get ready
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
you